at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey you guys what's going on look at
Tommy's like all posed like when the
thing goes over here
and it sounds to feel a little
understood today
slept all day man not feeling good
yeah maybe you're coming down with
something
I hope not because I'll probably lose
but you know
got some drinks yeah it's Wednesday I'll
drink it away it's the main show yeah
that's usually I'll just drink it away
it'll be all right usually yeah we're
going to be talking about serial killer
today I'm amazed that we haven't done
this guy before I've been wanting to do
a show on this guy for a really long
time yeah I remembered him I remember
his case what a [__] creep well not I
mean not like they all I mean they're
all obviously but um yeah this this
[__] guy he was a photographer
or so he said yeah and he'd uh try to
get these he had real good taste in
women he'd get these pretty girls he's
like we're gonna go out somewhere we'll
take some photographs of her and she'd
[__] disappear
and uh he had
they eventually ended up catching him
they went into one of his storage units
he had hundreds of pictures of girls
thousands thousands yeah well they're
just girls pictures of girls women and
boys too yeah okay
and they were um
they don't know who most of these people
are yeah they've been trying to like
find the people but thousands of photos
yeah they said it was just hundreds of
girls yeah and
um
some of them were a lot of them are so
explicit they can't show them so I don't
know exactly yeah they said um I think
that there's like 100 150 of them like
still on I think it might be on the
FBI's website
um but they said like 900 out of them
and they can't show them because they're
all like porn essentially
um you know or they're all nudes so were
they alive in the photos
yes but that's why they're confused
because they did know definitively they
found out later on that at least one of
the girls like one of the women in the
photos she did turn up dead so they
don't know now some of the women I think
like 20 21 women like after they you
know publicized photos they came forward
and said no that's me like you know what
I mean but um some of the people they
have never found them or they
disappeared or their families came
forward and said yeah we don't know
where our daughter is like she's been
missing for a really long time so some
of those women were in the in the uh the
nudes
yeah okay so according to them it was
just like a normal porn shoot
yeah I mean I guess so okay
but see that's the thing it's um so they
don't actually know I mean spoiler alert
Rodney Alcala is dead now he died in
2021 and good riddance
yeah but um they don't actually know how
many people he killed
um they they know for sure that he
killed eight
but
um the total could be many many more
than that uh could be as as high as 130
and actually some of the people that uh
that they found out that he killed like
later on were originally attributed to
the Hillside Strangler like another well
actually I should say Hillside
stranglers because there were two of
them I remember that case but yeah we
did it we did do a show about them right
um Ken Bianchi and uh Angelo buono I was
just too I was in California as a little
kid when those are going on
or at least they were talking about them
maybe on the news is that Hillside
strangle that was 70s right yeah this is
also seven okay yeah then I was there
and here's the [__] up thing and I was
like because I was watching a
documentary about this on my lunch hour
earlier and the crazy thing about this
was not only were the hillside
stranglers active at the same time as
Rodney Alcala but Son of Sam was active
at the same time as well and Rodney
Alcala went back and forth from LA to
New York so there were like serial
killers in both cities like there was
more than one serial killer like there
was a lot of serial killers in the 70s
you guys it was kind of like [__]
that leaded fuel
yeah we've talked about that but it had
to be something I mean 60s and 70s man
God damn it and like into the 80s too I
kind of feel like you know by the late
80s 90s it started like tapering off but
I mean you know there's someone around
when the lead started to [__] get
yeah I mean there's still murderers and
stuff like that but it really does seem
like this I think the 60s and 70s was
kind of like the Heyday yeah
but High population density areas
with people from all over collecting
there a lot of cars burning leaded fuel
it just and a lot of this everybody's
before the catalytic converter too in
some cases
and then I remember buying leaded
gasoline and put it in my car
driving it around yeah yeah like I
remember when I don't because I was like
pretty young then but it's like um I do
remember when you had the option you
know I do remember that yeah if you had
a older car you wanted leaded yeah I was
driving the [__] man Trey said was it 91
when they realized he had killed way
more than they thought yeah they didn't
actually find out until like later on
um you know that he and they did
actually were able to like link him
through DNA to like several other
murders that uh you know that hadn't
been solved DJ Maniac uh is here hey
where have you been
um said just drop in real quick before
work um Alcala was played by Cuban B
from Half Baked in a TV movie and it's
amazingly bad as you can imagine I did
actually see that that was on there and
I was like looking for it to watch but
it's like I couldn't I didn't have time
to watch it I'm watching what like it's
a TV movie about him oh okay I'm
surprised there's not more stuff about
him
and the reason they call him The Dating
Game Killer obviously is because he was
on The Dating Game In 1978 um and the
footage of it is everywhere like if you
want to see it and uh yeah he does come
across as pretty creepy although I have
to say that in the 70s everybody kind of
came across sort of creepy like that
yeah and he wasn't a bad looking guy he
had long hair and [__] took it he had
okay bone structure I mean he didn't
look like what you would consider to be
a serial killer to look like you look
just kind of well they they hardly ever
do that's that's why if you make a
beauty contest and you put him up there
with [__] uh Ted Bundy he probably
beat Ted Bundy what do you think
I don't know I'm not ranking the
attractiveness
I think he'd probably beat him I don't
think Rodney Alcala or Ted Bundy are
attractive I'm just saying that's not
what I asked you I said if you put him
in a beauty contest side by side I think
I think uh I think this guy would
probably beat Ted Bundy and Ted Bundy
was considered to be like
the better looking of the serial killers
I don't I don't think Rodney Alcala is
good looking at all
okay even with that stupid 70s hair
which is you know is not helping me
you're not playing this game no okay I
don't know I don't think he's I don't
think he's attractive at all I didn't
ask that is that what I asked I asked
between the two I think that this one is
like I said and what did I say I said
don't make me don't make me choose like
the most attractive serial killer I'm
not doing that
you know what I mean they're all [__]
up yeah okay Zach says uh plus this was
a generation of men raised by men messed
up by World War II which who knows what
kind of effect that had yeah I'm sure
that probably played into it some as
well maybe I mean yeah it could have
maybe it could have because yeah it was
kind of more the era of like um
the dads were kind of uh and I kind of
feel like this was all the generations
prior to that but the dads were kind of
like distant they weren't really like
super involved in like raising the kids
and
stuff like that so now they're
non-existent with a lot of the new
families so you know I don't know if
that's what it was
I think it was violence and sex being
merged for some reason and lack of
inhibition
uh lack of self-control it sounds like
[__] Mercury or lead poisoning that's
what it sounds like yeah the weird thing
about uh Rodney Alcala though was that
from everything that I could determine
he didn't seem like weird from a kid
because you know how sometimes serial
killers are like oh they started
torturing animals and [__] like that
um they said he seemed pretty normal
like until he was like in his late teens
or early 20s and even then like he
seemed pretty normal
but um you know like they said he didn't
they didn't really know that he had you
know tortured animals or done any of the
[__] that like serial killers do like
when they're younger they didn't know or
they or or he didn't do it apparently he
didn't do it I didn't see anything most
most of the things I said they I saw
that's like he wasn't abused he wasn't
anything like that
um the only kind of significant thing
that happened in his family life was
like his father left them when he was
like 12 I think
um but I don't think that's about it I
don't think Ted buddy did anything to
animals though either
yeah I don't think yeah he maybe he
didn't yeah that's not a
that's what a dead giveaway no but it is
like very very common that it's like a
really common yeah just a lot of damn
criminals too yeah well that's what I'm
saying but they're just saying that
Rodney Alexander as far as I know
um didn't really have any red flags from
childhood you know what I mean like he
didn't really see and like I said he
didn't seem to experience any horrible
abuse or anything like that like in his
childhood like he seemed
his childhood seemed fairly normal now
he did like um move back and forth
because his parents were Mexican
um and they had moved to San Antonio and
he was born in San Antonio and then
um they moved back to Mexico for a
little while but then like his dad left
and then they ended up him and his mom
and his him and his siblings like ended
up moving back to LA and living there
for a while but he seems like one of
those he is kind of like Ted Bundy in a
way in in the way that he didn't really
have like a bunch of like weird [__] in
his childhood that would explain like
why he was the way he was but he also
had that real like superficial
charm
um overconfidence
he um he also at his uh later trial
um he actually also defended himself but
he didn't do it this is gonna sound
weird he didn't do as well as Ted Bundy
because remember we did the show about
Ted money and I said how mad I was that
like the judge was like oh you should
have been a lawyer like instead of a
serial killer like he had made a great
I'm like don't know what happened to you
kid don't encourage that boy
um but yeah don't do that but uh so when
Rodney alakala did it though um he came
across as kind of like a crazy person
like not so much a crazy person but it's
just like somebody that was just like
well I don't know it's like [__] you
know what I mean it's yeah it's it's
something but he was like older too like
he was a lot older like by the time they
caught him so you know it's [__] ah
crazy Ted Bundy had some training as a
lawyer though I think didn't he yes uh
Rodney Alcala did not Rodney alcohol he
did uh graduate from college he
graduated from um from Art School uh and
also he went to NYU like he went to film
School studied under Roman Polanski
actually he had a he had a class like a
film class that was taught by Ryan
mcclansky and it's not that that like
made him a serial killer or anything
like that I think he probably already
killed people by that point but uh but
yeah
so um let's see yeah Camp guy said
Alcala and Bundy remind me of each other
yeah I think their pathologies are very
similar
um now I will say that Alcala didn't do
okay he didn't uh [__] severed heads as
far as anybody knows yeah
um but he did
he he did have that like sexual sadism
kind of thing where he was really into
uh he would like strangle a girl and
then like let her wake back up and then
strangle her again and like keep doing
it like you know what I mean he would do
[__] like that like oh it's like a
little bit of torture
and that kind of [__] so in a lot of
ways they are very similar I think Ted
Bundy was probably like more sick I
don't know if you want to like put it on
a spectrum they're all [__] up they're
all [__] up
yeah buddy walk around body parts that's
what I'm saying I don't think Alcala did
that although as I said they didn't
really catch him until later and then
after they found that warehouse at all
his pictures and they're like holy [__]
like maybe he killed a lot more people
than we thought so we're not really
entirely sure
what he did to some of the people and he
also went after like little girls like
12 13 year old girls also buddy though
yeah Bundy did he could although he
wouldn't admit it would he yeah you
never admitted it when he could he think
he did I think he got one or two of
those yeah
um
he was mean to them too so he he told
that one girl she was a little pig and
took her to the pig slaughterhouse and
cut her throat remember that
yep nasty [__] and then he would
uh that's that's Bundy yeah people don't
realize you know you see buddy walking
around you know from this
in in the courtroom with his suit and
you know him trying to look normal
that [__] was not normal man
yeah he would carry around heads he'd
keep a girl's head for a while just use
it as a sex toy I mean
yeah he was like the very definition
yeah not normal no a dude was not
[__] normal and um
I think he also do things kind of like
the Green River Killer if he had a good
looking girl dead somewhere out in the
woods I think he'd go back a couple
times to her if there was a necrophilia
happening I think he did that too I
remember correctly not all the time but
I think he did a couple times but or am
I mistaking that for somebody else I
thought he had a couple but I thought he
kept one girl's body stashed off the
side of the road in in a in an area and
went back to her a couple times over a
period of a few days I don't really
remember to be honest with you I think I
think I think he said he did that
sometimes the details of them kind of
blur together because we've done so many
shows about serial killers you know what
I mean
Trey said uh talking about Rodney Alcala
uh he was actually on the lamb for
raping an eight-year-old girl when he
went to film school yes that's true
because like I said he went back and
forth from LA to New York like kind of
trying to escape but it seemed like he
wasn't trying to escape all that hard
because yeah he used like a [__]
uh fake name and stuff but a lot of
times he used his real name he didn't
like try to change his appearance or
nothing like that he didn't really seem
like he was
sneaking around all that much and the
thing about it was that
I'm gonna say I kind of feel like uh the
justice system kind of um fell down on
this one because he got caught a few
times like earlier and he actually got
convicted a few times but then it always
ended up getting like overturned like on
various technicalities and stuff and so
he kept like getting back out you know
so I think the problem there was that
they had him in their in custody a few
times but he ended up getting out for
various reasons and then he would go and
like do it again you know what I mean
so do we have anything that we need to
cover before we get you gotta you all
right you gonna die no come on
I wanted to say um I don't think Louie
is here but it's like I think I
mentioned it on Sunday show or Monday
show but I can't really remember but I
always like to say it on the main show
so I want to give a shout out to Louie
for sending us some movies sent us the
steel book of Highlander and also sent
us Blackhawk Down right yeah we gotta
see those yeah so we're gonna be like
reviewing at least we'll at least one of
those like we'll probably do it on
Sunday let's let's do Highlander because
I don't want to do Highlander for a
while okay I mean it's up to you if you
want to do the other one first but it's
like it doesn't matter yeah I think I'd
put that in the poll a few times but it
just never wins but yeah so we'll be
doing that on Sunday and of course uh
we'll be doing the Side Track show we'll
do it Friday night this week
yeah yeah yeah because there's no reason
not to
because I don't think we're going any
place this weekend
so uh yeah all right so let's start
talking about this [__]
now Rodney Alcala is not it's not
exactly exactly like his real name his
real name when he was born was Rodrigo
Jacques Alcala bukor that was his name
now he was born in San Antonio in Texas
um now his parents were Mexican-American
like I said
now not too long after uh I believe
Rodney was just like a teenager or you
know or was a kid or something like that
but the whole family like moved to from
San Antonio to Mexico for a little while
and then three years later his dad just
took off and left and went and started a
new family somewhere else
so then in 1954 uh Rodney's about 11 and
his mom uh moved him and his siblings
she actually had two sisters
um to Los Angeles
now when Rodney was 17 this was in 1961.
he joined the army
now he didn't I said he didn't see any
action or anything like that it was just
like a clerk or whatever
so he was in there for three years
and he had what the military
psychiatrist termed a nervous breakdown
we're not really sure
um I've heard that it was maybe because
his father died because like I said his
father had abandoned them but I guess
maybe I don't know if he was still in
touch with him or whatever but I think
he found out that his father died and it
kind of like [__] him up a little bit
I don't know what the parameters of the
nervous breakdown were but that's what
they keep calling it
now during this particular uh episode he
actually went AWOL
and he ended up hitchhiking from Fort
Bragg where he was to his mom's house
now when they uh got hold of him and
they'd sent him to the psychiatrist the
military psychiatrist and this was in
you know the 1960s diagnosed him with
anti-social Personality Disorder so even
back then they knew probably something
was like the matter with him so he got
discharged from the Army on medical
grounds because that's because he was
diagnosed with that now they're not
entirely sure I was watching if you guys
um watch a YouTube channel it's Dr
Grande
and he does he puts up some like he puts
up a million videos he puts up something
like every day it seems like and he's
always like doing
um kind of a psychiatric evaluations of
various you know serial killers and
celebrities and he then he just just
does like General topics and stuff to
you and I was watching the Rodney Alcala
one
and um he's like yeah anti-social
personality disorder like from what we
know about him that does seem fairly
accurate
um but that he's been diagnosed by other
professionals as maybe narcissistic
personality disorder he said yeah that
seems pretty on the money as well maybe
borderline uh or malignant narcissism
with uh psychopathy and sexual sadism
comorbidities so uh yeah and as all
those sound pretty on the money like uh
at least from what you can tell like
you're looking at his behavior he's
crazy he's a dick uh he he's uh he beats
on women and that's uh what else
but that's that's basically all that
[__] means well you know it's all sounds
all high-tech
well it's not so much that because I
mean
anti-social personality disorder
narcissism borderline those are all very
specific things and they do have like
different
uh manifestations you know what I mean
it's not like just all the same thing
you know what I'm saying there are very
specific patterns of what they're
talking about yeah of General
description yeah personality types
I don't know if it's science but it is
you can describe people like this yes
there's only certain kinds of people
only certain kinds of purp you know what
I mean it might be 30 or 40 different
kind of personality types you know the
ones that are real bad are famous
yeah that's yeah and like I said this
this guy seems he came across very much
like Ted Bundy although
watching him at the trial like defending
himself the trial he didn't have the
same
[Music]
he didn't have the same level of that
just glib over confidence
that Ted Bundy had but similar you know
what I mean yeah you know I'm good at
sizing people up you know through my
experiences and sales and [__] like that
mind games and [__] with people
um Bundy came off as confident
but that was just the facade he would do
that to hide the fact that he was scared
yeah that's that's what he was doing
yeah you can see right through him well
that's what I meant when I said glib
over confidence that doesn't mean he was
actually confident that just means he's
like overcompensating he was scared and
he'd try a bunch of fast talking to
bamboozle people into thinking that he
was smarter than he really was he wasn't
that smart he was just parroting off
things that he thought smart people
would say yeah and and he had the
mannerisms of a smart guy but not the
substance you can see it when you if you
just watch well and that's the thing
it's like I feel like yeah maybe he
could fool some people but I don't think
he fooled most people I mean I don't
think he did he did a full movie yeah
it's just he just came across this very
it's like they always all serial killers
to me
come across as a role player
somebody who's LARPing yeah they never
come off as genuine even when they're
even when they're killing somebody like
like the damn
Charles Yang and [__] Leonard Lake
from the videos yeah tapes that survived
that I was able to see it doesn't even
look real
it looks like people LARPing as serial
killers
and I was really a victim that they have
and it just it just it seems it looks
really fake
sometimes I wonder if it's because
people that have those pathologies maybe
they're maybe there's nothing at their
core so they can't be genuine because
there's nothing there in there yeah so
every righteousness right so everything
is just kind of yeah and we've talked
about that before like maybe they don't
feel Consciousness the way the rest of
us do like or self-awareness so maybe
everything is a role that they're
playing because that's all they're doing
is they're just aping yeah other
people's behavior good examples gem is
coming out coming out of surgery and was
still under anesthesia and I talked to
her for a whole hour and she doesn't
remember it and during that time
anesthesia had shut her Consciousness
down so she was basically AI during that
time I really couldn't tell the
difference though
you know I'm not sure if I should be
offended by that
[Laughter]
no but but imagine if somebody was was
like that all the time you could
probably tell the difference right you
know what I mean because you
you were just you were behaving normally
from my point of view but you couldn't
remember any of it afterwards but I
didn't test you for for for cognition
you know what I mean whether
self-awareness I didn't test you of any
of that right there may be a way Stuart
hammeroff would know all about that
because he's big into all that kind of
research
and so it could be that certain brains
don't have Consciousness maybe they're
like an AI
I mean yeah there has to be something
because there really has to be something
fundamentally the matter with you to do
that to do this kind of stuff
and maybe you shut down your
Consciousness because your childhood was
bad or something
so it was just kind of shut down for
your own Survival but then that leads
you to being [__] ruthless serial
killer yeah it's possible
and I'm like I said it's got to be some
there has to maybe be some genetic
component involved too because some
people like riding Alcala like Ted Bundy
um they didn't as far as I know they
didn't have any kind of traumatic
childhood that would have engendered
that
so I mean there has to be some other
reason
why it happened you know what I'm saying
so I don't really know
but yeah so yeah they both come across
as kind of just like douchey
it's rare overconfidence it's rare that
people do this so yeah thankfully so it
must be a combination of many rare
things all happening all happening at
once yeah so it's something genetic
maybe something organic or it might have
been brain damaged on top of it then
there was like some kind of a weird
neglect in the family uh and then there
was maybe like I don't know bullying at
school or something and then it all
starts and then they're in an
environment where they can get away with
this then there's some kind of sexual
turmoil going on and you know what I
mean and it all kind of adds up into
this like a perfect storm you know
yeah it has to be like uh just a whole
bunch of different things yeah it can't
be one thing or be a lot more common
yeah which like I said it's not I mean
it's more common than uh it should be
but the reason that people are so
fascinated by them is because it's so
unusual I have a feeling that they're
not aware
that they're AI biological AI
somehow they shut down their own
consciousness
no ability to have introspection no
ability to have empathy for anybody else
and there's a lot of people that's like
that though they don't have empathy for
other people yeah
um and it's very very common but it's
usually not this bad
yeah yeah I think a lot of people have
that but not to the extent where they'd
like kill somebody but they but for sure
they'll just like [__] you over like
because they'll be like oh well me me
you know what I mean yeah so this is
just like the extreme of that yeah I
suppose I mean it's it's very common
right now with young people not being
able to predict what somebody else would
do if they do something else in other
words they don't understand cause and
effect yet there's a lot of that it's
being video documented you know and it
has something to the way they're being
raised
it's impeding on their ability to
predict what will happen if you do or
say certain things that's weird if you
ask me
we're in the age of [__] around and find
out
but some people haven't realized that
I don't know
yeah I mean if you say something
Crossways to somebody he's gonna punch
you
but I don't understand why that isn't a
given you know
that's weird don't you think
yeah I think so too
I mean I grew up from an early age you
know and that if you insulted somebody
in high school they'd punch you
you know
but I guess the they didn't think the
world's like that I guess
yeah but you have empathy for the person
if I said that to me I'd [__] punch
me too yeah I remember they don't have
empathy I'm gonna punch myself yeah yeah
right
but yeah so uh all right so where was I
let's see so he gets out of the army
like I said and then he went to uh
California and he went to UCLA School of
Fine Arts and he actually graduated from
there
now
from what they know okay now this is the
start of his [__] criminal career
here even though most of his murders
were in the 70s and I kind of feel like
he's mostly a city associated with the
late 70s however his first crime that
they know of uh was committed in 1968.
now what happened here was that he was
in LA
and he lured an eight-year-old girl
named tally Shapiro
into his apartment
um not really sure how he did that
um I think he said something about uh he
knew her her parents or something like
that
so thankfully
somebody
um like a like a bystander or a witness
that was driving by like saw him luring
the girl and like taking her into the
and he thought it looked weird
so he followed the car he followed uh
I'll call his car and followed him to
the address and then he wrote down the
address and then he went back to the
Payphone and he called the cops
so the cops got to the house and they
knock on the door and
um Rodney is just like cool as a
cucumber and he's like oh just give me a
minute you know I'm not dressed or
something like that and they do for some
stupid reason and he runs out the back I
heard he was completely naked he just
ran out the back like naked or whatever
so the cops bust in the house and this
little eight-year-old girl is on death's
door she's like laying there on the
floor he's she's been raped
um he beat her with a steel bar in the
head like he cracked her [__] skull
open or whatever they did find her alive
she was all [__] up but I mean thank
that Good Samaritan that like saw the
[__] and like saw it looked weird and
thought it looked weird and followed the
dude so that little girl will be dead
because they said if the cops hadn't got
there that quick that she would have
died like from her injuries but they did
find her but you know that's good that
they saved her but Rodney got away you
know because he was like oh hang on just
a second then he's like he and then like
he runs naked out the [__] back door
and like you know skedaddled so uh yeah
so after that he's like oh well better
leave La for a while because you know
raping and almost murdering an
eight-year-old girl yeah that'll put a
little crimp in your style won't it she
didn't seem to bother him that much
well yeah that's what I'm saying like
what the [__] man
well I guess I could get policing back
then what wasn't what it was you could
probably leave a county and the counties
probably didn't talk to each other very
well yeah I mean this was like 60s and
70s so it's not like now where you know
you go anywhere and they can instantly
find out where your stupid ass is at
right yeah but back then they didn't and
like I said he could he would went back
and forth across the country all the
time he's like hey it changed his name
and rolled in schools all this other
kind of [__] like with it you can't do
that [__] anymore I mean you can but
it's like a lot harder they'd notice it
yeah that's what I mean it's like you
really really have to like know your
[__] to get away with it nowadays you're
just like yeah
so uh so he decides he's going to go
across the country so he goes to New
York
and uh as I mentioned before enrolled at
NYU at the film School
and he enrolls under a pseudonym John
Berger or I guess Burger because it's
b-e-r-g-e-r okay
so he enrolls there like I said you know
he had a class under Roman Polanski not
necessarily uh relevant but you know
what I mean I just thought I would
mention it because I thought it was a
fun fact
and uh also so he's going there and then
in 1971
he got a job as a counselor at an Arts
camp like a children's art camp in New
Hampshire I think it was like a drama
type Camp you know what I mean like over
the summer
and he used a different Alias at that
and it's like in that place he used the
Alias John Berger like hamburger you
know what I mean
now interestingly coincidentally not
coincidentally
in June of 1971
um a 23 year old woman named Cornelia
Crilley
she um worked for TWA she was a flight
attendant and they found her raped and
strangled in her apartment in Manhattan
now they didn't actually know that
Rodney Alcala had killed her until
2011. like when they were doing like
some DNA and [__] like that but this was
around the time because he was in New
York and he killed like some women there
as well
and they didn't know that until like
much later on
now
okay so because he had fled California
and because he had raped and you know
attempted murder on an eight-year-old
girl um you know the FBI are not gonna
like look too kindly on that and they
knew that he had left the state so the
FBI put him on the 10 most wanted
fugitives list in 1971. now
interestingly remember how I said that
he was uh at a camp counselor at like
this Arts camp in New York right or in
New Hampshire rather
so it so happened that he was on like
the most wanted poster or whatever and
they put it like in all the post offices
these two kids that were in his art camp
they went into the post office like in
New Hampshire I don't I've heard that it
was because it started raining and they
ran in there or they went in there to
mail a letter or something and they saw
his picture on the poster
they said hey that looks like our
camp counselor whose name is John Berger
so the two kids
they called the [__] FBI yeah it said
hey you might want to like come check
this [__] [__] out yeah
because this looks just like our [__]
yeah yeah so uh so I was like good on
those kids you know what I mean they
keep trying to catch this [__]
they offer rewards though too we gonna
get that money 25
000 yeah we're gonna spit well hey
they're welcome
I don't know how old the kids were but
yeah that's right 25 000 for the Jolly
Ranchers yeah but like I said
fire stick yeah but like I said they're
welcome to it because I feel like most
people don't even look at those posters
and it's like wouldn't be observant
enough to be like hey look at that
[__] I know who that is and then
like to actually go through and like
call the number and [__] like that but
yeah so and you know back then it was a
lot harder to do you had to like find a
payphone you couldn't just like pick up
your [__] phone out of your pocket
and do it you know what I mean well they
were they were at the post office though
yeah that's true they're probably filmed
right there yeah yeah they're like hey
we're gonna come on maybe maybe they
hated him and he was an [__] instead
of like we're gonna turn this [__] in
it I don't know you just look up there
and you see you see that face and you go
that look at that reward there was gonna
be reward money right next to it yeah
okay for one for murder that's I think
that's that dude man that's him yeah
that's probably what it was that's
probably what they said yeah it's like
well let's call it yeah that's good
chi-ching I wonder if they get everyone
because if it's not him then there's no
harm done right
yeah that's true yeah
so uh so yeah so he did get arrested
actually and he got extradited to
California
now here's the shitty thing well you
know okay
so they took him back to California and
he was supposed to stay on trial for the
rape and attempted murder like oh and
kidnapping too actually of the
eight-year-old girl
um Tali Shapiro however by the time that
they got him back to California
um the little girl's parents had taken
her back to Mexico and they did not want
her to testify at the trial because she
was just little and they didn't really
want to put her through that like I get
it
um it kind of sucks because
you know he's gonna get out you know
he's gonna get away with like but I can
understand like why you want because she
was just a little girl and they didn't
like want her to go through with it and
they just like went back to Mexico
I'm not flying with that though no well
I'm just saying it freeze him to go do
that again I know I know that's the
shitty thing and it's like there's
really no winning in that situation
that's what's crappy about it you know
what I mean like I understand why you
know you have an eight-year-old daughter
and you don't want to put her through
that [__] but like I said you have to
think of like the bigger picture too
it's like you know if you don't testify
like what if he gets out and like does
it to somebody else and then there's
like more because he did do it to
somebody else yeah they do that once
it's because that's part of them they're
gonna continue doing it yeah until
they're stopped yeah there's not they
don't do that well I'm just gonna do it
once no it's like oh that's enough for
me no yeah part of their sexual
orientation yeah
so uh so yeah so she didn't testify so
what they ended up doing
um because they didn't have the main
witness they're like okay well we can't
charge him with rape or attempted murder
now uh so they did convict him of child
molestation though so they sentenced him
to three years
so that was something at least however
uh he only served 17 months and then he
got paroled and this was in 1974.
now he was only out for at least it was
less than two months he was out of jail
and then he got arrested again
for sexually assaulting uh a 13 year old
girl
who has as far as I know um I don't know
if they've ever said her real name they
just called her Julie J
um she was basically like waiting for uh
the bus like to go to school and he
lured her into the car
and you know kidnapped her and attacked
her
so yeah now he's lured her into the car
um that's the thing like that's
something like your dad sent me down
here to get you I think that's how he
got the first girl like he was like oh
well you know I know your parents and
they said yeah because that's something
that like a lot of [__] child
molesters and [__] like that used to use
it's like oh you know I'm I know your
mom and dad and uh they told me to come
get you because they're they were in an
accident or something like that like
I've seen him pull trying to pull [__]
like that yeah so can I tell you what
when we were little kids down in
California
we had that [__] drilled into our heads
by the time we were seven or eight
enough to talk strangers yeah yeah same
I remember one time I was out there with
Jimmy and Mike Jimmy was the same age as
me he's probably about eight and Mike
was little was his older brother who was
probably about 10. and some dude in a
car pulled up to us while we were out in
the front front yard and he just goes he
goes hey what he goes what's the name of
this what street is am I on what street
is this we scattered man yeah and that
dude I don't that dude probably didn't
even meet really mean anything he
probably yeah we ain't talking to you
you only get murdered yeah took off I'd
be like I'll be staying way over here
I'm like uh it's on the sign can't you
[__] read yeah you can't read maybe
you shouldn't be driving what the name
of the street was
yeah that's something that they will do
a lot that they used to do it's like oh
yeah yeah they would always kind of like
pull up and be like hey I'm kind of lost
yeah I'd be like oh well sucks to be you
get a map
I'm going home
but yeah
so but yeah I think for sure
um the the girl that uh the first girl
that he attacks I'm pretty sure that he
said something about that he knew her
parents and [__] like that so that he
was going to take her someplace
but yeah so um so he attacks this 13
year old girl
and he uh went to prison this time for
two years and he got paroled again in
1976 or 1977.
now so he's on parole and he has a
parole officer in LA
and for whatever reason God they it
seemed like even though the 70s was like
the Heyday of serial killers or some
[__] serial killers running around
like on every [__] corner but
everybody was just like so
casual about just like letting oh sure
it's fine like just let him out you know
what I mean they let him go to New York
because he's like oh he's gonna go visit
relives they're like okay it'll be fine
even though they knew that he was a
sexual offender they knew that he had
taken off before
you know what I mean like after he had
an awareness of it they did it I I
remember in the 80s on television there
were big campaigns to try to get the law
and law enforcement and to get Society
to realize that sexual predators were a
real thing and that they were all pretty
much always repeat offenders yeah and
that was like something that was not in
the public Consciousness that these guys
were like multiple sex offenders they
didn't
yeah I kind of feel like maybe they
hadn't really fully grasped that
situation they thought it was just a
one-time thing no that's not what they
were they didn't know what they were
dealing with
I think it took psychologists criminal
psychologists to [__] trying to kind
of educate
Society in the system to who these
things were their things they're not
people
but yeah that's the thing so the parole
officer apparently no problem at all
sure go to New York and
um you know and see your family or
whatever even though that obviously
wasn't what he was doing there's no
difference between a serial killer and a
serial rapist it's the same thing
because the serial killer kills the
victim so he can go on to rape that's
all it is yeah I mean and um they
they start off as peeping Toms a lot of
times and weird [__] like that they
always start off as a sex offender
that they're they end up becoming serial
killers usually it's uh just it's the
same psychology over and over again it's
just different it's just a uh it's a
spectrum they
um
once they take that plunge and start
killing people they never come back they
get worse
yeah because they have to keep like
ramping it up
yeah and now we're saying it's like a
spectrum and I'm not you know saying
this to excuse anybody but like
sometimes you get people that are like
peeping Toms or you know people that are
like [__] flashers and [__] like that
and that's all they do like that's as
far as they go yeah but it doesn't
usually as serial killers have gone
through those phases but yeah but see
that's the thing you never know if like
oh they're just gonna stay at that level
which is not a good level but I'm just
saying that it's like are they just
gonna stay there where they're like
flashing their Willy at people yeah in
their in cars and [__] all the time
they're on the bus because I've run into
a couple of those yeah but um or is it
just gonna escalate because sometimes it
does but you and you never know like
starts off so dudes he's flashing he's
[__] showing people his [__] and then
people learn to evade that then he gets
into I'm gonna look at them so he's
looking into people's windows all right
and then it goes into I'm gonna go in
that house
and that's then it starts getting more
dangerous and then he goes I'm gonna go
in that house and I'm gonna rape that
woman
and then he does some time for it and
then the next time he goes I'm gonna go
in that house and rape that woman then
kill her so I don't get sent back to
prison and then it starts the whole
thing you know the Killer part of is
pretty good too and that's a real common
pattern yeah and it just grows into that
they don't all do that but that was
evidently a pretty common pattern
is that serial rapists start off usually
as like flashers and [__] yeah like
low level like yeah and then they start
going into people's houses Defenders
yeah and then they evolve into a serial
killer
yeah it is uh yeah yeah
okay so um so they let him go to New
York like I said
now they think now they didn't know this
at the time they found this out later on
but they think that about a week after
he arrived in New York City
he murdered a woman
a 23 year old Ellen Ellen Jane hover now
she was actually kind of a prominent uh
uh person she was actually
um her dad owned Ciro's nightclub like a
really famous like nightclub in
Hollywood and Dean Martin and Sammy
Davis Jr were her Godfathers sir so she
was kind of like well known in certain
like uh Social Circles or whatever so
um but yeah she turned up dead in her uh
they found her um on a hillside like on
the Hudson River
in North Tarrytown in New York and uh
and they didn't know who killed her for
a long time but they figured out later
that it was probably Alcala and that was
like about a week after he um arrived
there from New York like he was or
arrived there from L.A because he was on
uh parole
now
1978 he goes back to LA for a Time
and he actually got a job even though
he's a multiple sex offender he's on
parole all this other kind of [__] he
gets a job at the Los Angeles Times like
as a typesetter
now as I mentioned earlier there was a
bunch of high profile serial killer
cases going on at this time among them
the Hillside Strangler case
and Rodney Alcala matter of fact was
interviewed by the Hillside Strangler
task force because they were
interviewing like all the sex offenders
like in the area like to see who it was
and it was like well if he was at the
Hillside Strangler but he was like
another serial killer I'm like Jesus
Christ can you imagine like the [__]
70s man serial killers everywhere but
yeah
so he got ruled out for that even though
they did find out later on they didn't
find this out until later on like I said
but um that one of the one of the women
that they attributed to the hillside
strangle they suspected was the Hillside
Strangler was actually Rodney Alcala but
they did interview him in the Hillside
Strangler investigation because he was a
sex offender and that's they were
interviewing all of them but so like I
said he's not the Hillside Strangler but
he was another [__] [__] yeah
so during this time period was when he
started doing his whole hey I'm a
photographer schtick
and this apparently it worked because he
got a lot of people
to pose for him it wasn't just women it
was women girls
um teenage boys like some younger men
like anybody that he could get to
pose for him and he took pictures of
them and he took like thousands and
thousands of pictures most of them like
I feel like 90 of them were like porny
you know what I mean or like nudes or
whatever but but he was able to convince
a lot of people that he was like this
big shop photographer or whatever and
because like I said he was working at
the Los Angeles Times one of the people
that worked there when he worked there
they said that he would like show people
the photographs of like people at work
like it's like hey look at these and
they're like okay that's a little bit
weird that you're showing us naked
pictures of your he's like oh I'm a
photographer he's proud of so I guess
that's how he could like get away with
it they were tasteful news I don't know
I kind of got the Feeling maybe not but
that's what I mean and I think some of
them were underage too so it's like that
nowadays like alarms will be going off
and everybody comes to be showing up the
fans would be showing up and [__] like
that should you know but uh back then
people just like uh okay yeah
thank you Jack Torrance yeah thank you
Jack Torrance is in the house
but yeah so
um but yeah they did actually interview
some of the women that he had
photographed back then because he didn't
kill all of them thankfully but
um they were just like yeah they just
thought that he would you know was a
professional photographer they didn't
think anything that weird about it
because they didn't see through the
facade but yeah so well apparently a lot
of people didn't because like I said he
photographed like hundreds and hundreds
of people and it wasn't all just women
and girls either like it was so he must
have had some decent manners and
mannerisms about him where
he didn't kill them all
so he would just put you know if he
guess if he liked her or maybe he didn't
like her that much he just took pictures
of her maybe if he liked her a lot he
killed her
yeah maybe something like that I mean
and they suspect too that like some of
the people he took pictures of like he
might have killed him and they just
haven't found them yet yeah another
thing is is that maybe he wanted to take
pictures of some of them and then they
started bailing out and he killed him
might have been something yeah that's
what I mean because they don't know how
many people this [__] killed and
it's probably they probably never find
out now because he's [__] dead
although they did um you know they did
get his DNA so they might be able to
like match it like with cold cases and
stuff like later on but they did think
that around this time period there was
um a girl who was 15 at the time her
name was Monique Hoyt and uh he was
taking pictures of her and he didn't
kill her but he like knocked her
unconscious and raped her so he did do
that like they're pretty sure he did
that and so like I said he might have
killed other people he got away or he
got away she how did she live he didn't
intend to kill her I don't know but she
just she hit her with his fist don't
know okay he usually um
I think in some of the cases he used
like metal bars or pipes or things like
that and he just thought he killed her
he was a Strangler also he must have
thought he killed him he was real into
either strangle his bare hands or he
strangled with like nylons and pant legs
and [__] like that
the only explanation for that is that he
thought he killed her and left her for
now yeah
unless you heard otherwise from that
from that case no I hadn't heard
otherwise why why bother why bother
knocking her out
you know what I mean if you're not going
to kill her yeah
whatever if you're not gonna kill her
you know what I mean
well yeah and well because you're the
reason why you kill them is so you don't
do the time for the rape right okay so
if you're gonna rape or you're gonna
kill her well like I said that first
little girl that he's like the
eight-year-old
um he had intended to kill her and they
said that she would have died if the
cops hadn't got there like quickly
because the injuries were so severe
but she did live uh Jack torrent says
nice hair Jenny thank you
it's not real hair it's imaginary hair
[Laughter]
well it's just because my real hair is
kind of messy because it looks anyway
doesn't do it well I guess it can kind
of keep you warm kids keep your head
warm yeah keeps keeps your brain head
warm here though that's like a mullet
yeah you keep the back of my dick
yeah
yeah those dudes would park the [__]
down the middle and have the sword have
had the brush around the side I know I'm
like like the head was a circumcised
penis dick head literally
remember those old [__] haircuts I do
too that's [__] I don't understand it
I don't either yeah but somehow like
everybody had like Collective psychosis
where they all thought it looks good at
the same time yeah so this is delusion
can you yeah can you imagine like that
somebody else and being like yeah I want
that do that to my hand I want a
[__]
the mass delusion
oh my God
uh Juan just got here hi Tom and Jenny
yeah we didn't we we only started at 7
30 so we ended because like I said I I
got a [__] full-time job now so I'm
not getting home till late at night
um all right so now we're talking about
the infamous Dating Game appearance
and keep in mind that this [__]
has already raped and killed several
people and his little girl tried to kill
her and he killed several people after
his appearance on The Dating Game also
but nobody knew this even though he used
his real name
you can see it on the it's like it's on
YouTube they didn't have Google back
there
yeah and I guess they didn't check and I
guess it's just like the stupid dating
game so it's not like they're gonna do a
background yeah nothing like that no
but no that's funny that he well that he
he's using his real name on The Dating
Game and he's the same dude that beat
that eight eight-year-old girl nearly to
death well that's what's so [__]
creepy about watching it because you
know that he did that I guess he knew
well the parents they went back to
Mexico
you know that [__] blew over that was a
long time ago they'll think I'm a
different guy yeah same name different
guy yeah whatever yeah
it worked
well yeah I mean that she did actually
when she grew up like she came in like
uh testified at one of his other trials
like when she was growing up yeah well
no I'm saying so it worked if they
didn't they didn't find him yeah yeah
for a long time
now I'm kind of confused because the
dating game they didn't film it live and
I heard because like I watched a couple
documentaries about this and I think on
one of the documentaries they said that
the taping of it was actually 10 months
before the actual airing of it which
seems like a long lead time to me but so
I don't know if that's true but I just
remember hearing that because I was like
wow that seems like a really long time
because I thought they did them like
just a couple weeks out you know what I
mean but I don't know 10 months seems
like a long time so I don't really know
so this [__] shows up on The
Dating Game so the host's name was Jim
Lang
and um they're you know three bachelors
and I don't know if you know how the
game worked it was like super [__]
cheesy but they had like The Bachelors
were all like behind a screen so like
The Bachelorette uh couldn't see them
she could just like ask them questions
and she could like hear their voices and
stuff and then she had to pick one
without like seeing them and then they'd
pay for them to go out on a date or
whatever
so so there's three guys on there and
Rodney is you know bachelor number one
so he gets introduced as a quote-unquote
successful photographer
um and also that he was into
motorcycling and skydiving which I think
was probably [__] he just wanted to
seem like all daring and yeah I jump out
of things and action oriented and [__]
like that I'm like whatever dude because
there's no no reports of him skydiving
or riding a motorcycle I mean maybe he
did I don't know but it's just like to
me it just seemed like he was trying to
like beat the show off no he likes that
[__] he doesn't do it he's just like
yeah I like watching it on TV yeah yeah
yeah
yeah that's like them chicks that
[__] like uh the online dating
profiles you know what I mean oh yeah I
like skydiving and water skiing and
climbing the [__] Mount Everest but
they haven't done any of that [__] they
just like it yeah they like thinking
about it but maybe they'll do it yeah
yeah they like watching other people do
it yeah I like climbing volcanoes
yeah I'm a big advocate of like if
you're gonna do a cheap trailer yeah if
you're gonna do a profile like that just
like write down what you really like
right like what you really like what you
do what you like to do what you actually
do what yeah like what you like to do
that you actually do instead of just
just don't be like aspirational I like
sitting on my couch watching Ricky Lake
we'll see if it's like other people like
to do that too so it's a little bit more
yeah that's what I mean because then at
least you'll find somebody that likes to
do the same [__] as you yeah you know
what I mean don't try to be like all
aspirational you're gonna get busted
yeah it's like you know there's like you
don't know anything about skydiving I
like sitting around smoking blunt
yeah so you just got to be honest that's
all don't don't try to be like all
[__]
feel like all special
ride motorcycles in skydiving unless you
actually do that I know some people do
actually do that but I just got the
feeling that he was trying to like be
show offy
so um so yeah
now here's what's gross like I was
watching The Dating Game appearance I've
seen it a couple of times
and the whole thing about the dating
game this is the 70s man they had the
same thing with like The Newlywed Game
and all that kind of crap where they
would
um all of the questions and answers and
stuff were like super like all like
double entender like sexual and
innuendos and stuff and everybody just
thought that was hilarious which it's
really not it's like really cringy well
they have censorship back then yeah but
I mean well actually it wasn't it was
actually a lot more relaxed back then
than it is I think
well I don't know if I'd say that but
it's just like I don't know it's just
like the shit's just like so it's so
cheesy it's so cheesy yeah so television
the question that um her name is Cheryl
Bradshaw that was the name of the um the
woman that was The Bachelorette
and the question she asked him was
something like
um you know you're what is it I'm I'm
gonna eat you or you're a food or
something like that like what like what
food are you and what are you like or
what do you taste like or something like
that and he just has like this [__]
smarmy ass expression and he's like I'm
a banana and I taste really good and I'm
just like
okay whatever I'm just like I was
creative it wasn't too creative oh he's
a banana yeah yeah it's a dick joke yeah
I was like that's about what I'd expect
and then uh she said something like she
seemed like kind of interested in it
because I guess she doesn't have any
standards but I'm just no I'm just
kidding but um
but then she asked like a follow-up
question and and he said like he said
peel me and I was like
no thank you no thank you I would rather
not do that
um and then also she also asked him God
they asked him like the weirdest [__]
questions and she said I want you to
role play as like a dirty old man
or something I'm like okay I was like
what Jesus the drugs back then yeah
I was like why would you even think to
ask that so he was just like back there
going yeah come over here like that I'm
just like oh my God this is so [__]
gross so yeah so there was two other
guys on there too
um but you know she was apparently all
about Rodney
from his banana answer because she was
just like ooh bananas
but
um when because like I said she couldn't
see him she could only like hear him and
like hear like his answers to her
questions
so later on he like she picked him
so he won
and then they uh we're gonna send him on
I think they were gonna go to what's
that [__] theme park they were gonna
send this theme park and they'd be like
tennis lessons and that kind of [__]
because you know 70s it's all about
tennis lessons back then yeah tennis
lessons and fondue parties yeah crazy
I love hotels I love hotels and [__]
like that yeah and uh and then [__]
Singapore slings
they probably would have yeah however
uh once Cheryl Bradshaw interacted with
uh Rodney Alcala backstage uh she went
to the producers and said um I'm not
going out on a date with him he's creepy
yeah which I was like yeah you don't
know the half of it so uh yeah she
dodged a [__] bullet on that one
literally so she didn't have to go with
it no she didn't go yeah she because she
went out again she said once she like
actually interacted with him in person
she was like oh no no no no and actually
the other two guys actually on a
documentary I saw that I think came out
in 2017 and they actually had the one of
the other guys that was um that was on
the show like The Bachelor he was an
actor and um he's like yeah I thought he
was like pretty weird too like when we
were talking in the green room and stuff
they said he just was real weird and
it's like he had just like really he
said he had bizarre opinions right
that's what he said
um and he just said he just seemed I
don't know just like really and he said
he seemed like one of those dudes that
like um
that acted like he knew everything yeah
you know what I mean like he was one of
those like like I said like like
overconfident right and he was just like
so he's like real obnoxious and like
just he just like I don't know I just
didn't like him he just like rubbed me
the wrong way yeah weird so a lot of
people like notice it but like when he
was on the show
you know apparently nobody thought
anything but once people were
interacting with him one by one they
were just like yeah what his bizarre
opinions were they're probably about
women
I'm yeah I'm imagining that's why that's
why the guy brought it up yeah
but yeah he probably said some real
interesting [__] about women yes
probably now some people have speculated
that
um the fact that Cheryl Bradshaw like
that that he won the show and then later
on she renegged on it and said no I'm
not going out with that creepy ass
[__] that maybe this
caused his [__] to escalate I don't know
though because I kind of feel like he'd
killed people before this yeah they just
need to be escalated so I don't really
know I mean it's possible and the thing
about it is that like because some you
know some like research some you know
psychiatrists or whatever has said that
well you know he does have Psychopathic
Tendencies and a lot of times
Psychopaths have a hard time with
rejection like especially like when a
woman rejects them
um they don't really because they don't
really have like any insight like oh
maybe I did something like to piss her
off or something like that like oh
there's something wrong with her like
[__] women you know what I mean they
kind of go in that direction so I don't
know I I think it's maybe to
easy to say that just because he got
rejected on The Dating Game like
afterward that uh that that like caused
the escalation of the crimes yeah I
think those dudes know that there's
something wrong with them though
like when a woman rejects them I think
they're already pre-rejected they know
that they're they I think those guys
know that they're different but they
don't want to admit that to themselves
so they just [__] turn it around on
back on everybody else that's what I
think
they have to know that they're different
or they wouldn't do the things that
they're doing
just you know that's the thing though
it's like but we but we were talking
about that earlier like how much Insight
do they really have about their own
psychology or their own behavior I think
they know that they're different they
wouldn't be hiding what they're doing
because they yeah that's actually hide
what they do because they do know what
they're doing is wrong otherwise they
would just be like [__] doing it all
the yeah be doing the open yeah well
that's kind of the definition of that's
how you get an insanity defense if
you're just because you're like
obviously you don't know that or you
don't care if it's wrong or you don't
know they know that they're different
but they know there's nothing they can
do about it and uh they like the way
that they are so they just kind of lash
out at everybody else yeah
I can't believe they don't like me
[__] raping and killing these [__]
this is ridiculous that's what they're
that's that's like that
yeah I believe it yeah look at D'Angelo
yeah that's the way [__] D'Angelo was
like that yeah
breaking into your house [__] with
[__] killing you and your husband and
[__]
and he thought it was ridiculous that he
couldn't do that
yeah are you crazy yeah why is everybody
craving my style man yeah yeah [__]
hold me back man
I need to be me yeah yeah yeah
yeah no we'd rather you not be you yeah
okay you just you just tone that down
can't believe it
it's so prejudiced
my freedom yeah yeah
exactly
that's they're like the epitome of that
kind of mother yeah okay what about my
freedom because I'm raping and killing
people
I imagine one of them is like in a
[__] truck
oh yeah
it's like I'm I'm just waiting for the
day one of them tries to argue that [__]
in court you know well I can take I can
take the worst elements within myself
and magnify them and and apply them to
that situation and that's what I would
be doing so that's what they're doing
yeah I know that's you know and that's
not pulling that out of nowhere no I
know I I've known people that thought
that way like not not about rape and
murder that I never you know most people
do that they just don't do it in that
situate to that right to that degree you
know but that's what they're doing it
you know it's got to be well and like I
said we and I think we've mentioned this
before and like I said this is very very
general
but I do feel like in very very general
terms
usually men tend to project stuff
outward as they tend to project blame
outward like if something goes wrong oh
that [__] did it whereas women
tend to project it inward I [__] up
I'm I'm messed up I'm you know I I'm a
terrible person or I you know don't know
how to do anything so that's and you
know obviously there's a lot of
variation on that but I kind of feel
like serial killers that kind of suffer
people with that kind of attitude that's
like the an extreme of that because
you're just blaming everybody else well
you know you see it a lot with like Mass
Shooters and stuff like that where it's
like they're gonna blame the whole
[__] world or look at like
[__] like Elliot Roger or
something like that because I'm gonna
kill all the women like people I don't
even [__] know because one girl
wouldn't talk to me or something like
that like he like everybody has a
responsibility to him yeah something
else man yeah like he really seemed to
think that everybody had a
responsibility to him to like oh well I
you know I'm good looking and I have a
car and I'm so obviously women should
just like come to me and it's like he
didn't really think that he had to do
anything other than that and so the fact
that was awkward as [__] too and the
fact that like people weren't just like
falling down at his feet or being or
like calling him up or paying attention
to him like somehow that was everyone
else's fault yeah and the dude is
obviously is insane he's got some kind
of a mental uh yeah it's obvious
you know
um but no that that's what they're doing
they're like you know I can't believe
these [__] you know I'm just trying
to kill the [__] up in here I
mean they're bad they know they're bad
it's got to be done that's what you know
the Green River Killer I think was kind
of like that they're just hookers you
know yeah
somebody's got to do it and everybody
else does it it's that that's the thing
that that's what they're thinking yeah
well yeah that's how they yep justify it
to themselves
it's just uh I like I understand it I
understand it because I've heard people
talk like that like not murderers but I
have heard people like talk like have
that kind of attitude so I understand
that people like I don't
I don't understand it personally because
I don't think like that
she shouldn't have worn that skirt it's
that same [__] yeah I know she should
be dressing like that everybody knows
you're not supposed to dress like that
out in public at late at night in this
part of town when I'm around yeah you
know there's just their fault yeah yeah
it's their fault she knew I'd be here
you know this is that kind of [__] yeah
that's that's yeah yeah I I feel like
that's probably she got what she
deserved yeah
yeah that's that's very she made me do
it that's very common yeah and not just
among serial killers either yeah like I
think a lot of people think like that
yeah it's just serial killers are taking
it even though you're wrong wrong
extreme yeah yeah if you think it's just
a childish way of thinking it is it is
well it's um it's a it's a um like I
said I think it is kind of childish
because you're kind of seeing everything
from your your very self-absorbed self
yeah you know you don't understand that
like other people are also having their
own will have their own will and their
own thing to do it's like everybody just
has to cater to you like world revolves
around you which like I said is a very
very child life right yeah way of
thinking like you can't most people grow
out of that but some people never do no
but that's what I'm seeing with mostly
serial killers is that
yeah it's it's a it's a type of
entitlement right
because they want something that means
that they are entitled to it yep you
know they don't they don't think well
that girl didn't like
she did she was just like living her own
life you know yeah she didn't like ask
to be at the end of your whatever yeah
you know what I mean right
so um so yeah so not long after The
Dating Game appearance
there was a 12 year old girl uh from
Huntington Beach in California her name
was Robin samso
and she was on the beach one day with a
friend of hers and she actually had to
go to her ballet class this was June
20th 1979 and she was running a little
bit late for her ballet class so she
actually borrowed um a yellow Schwinn
bicycle from her friend so she could
ride the bike there however
somewhere along the way she disappeared
they found her body decomposed 12 days
later in the foothills of Los Angeles
now later on when they talked to Robin
samso's friend that she'd been with on
the beach she said yeah there was this
weird guy that like came up to us like
earlier in the day and was asking to
take pictures of us these were like 12
year old girls it's like yeah we want to
do like a swimsuit model type of thing
and they're just like okay like what the
[__] ever like they thought it was weird
um now interestingly the friend was able
to give the cops a description and I've
seen the sketch and it looks almost
exactly like him so I was like damn way
to go kid that was like a really good
description uh because the sketch is
very very similar to him
now uh interestingly alcala's parole
officer was the one that Ricky's like
hey that's like he saw the sketch and
he's like hey that's Rodney wait hold on
where did he get that girl and get get
that girl separate from the other one
because the other girl was going to her
ballet class okay so she so she left her
there alone right right well could yeah
well the friend yeah the friend was on
the beach they were on the beach
together yeah Rodney had come up to them
and said hey I want to take your picture
and they were like yeah no and then
she's like oh I gotta go to my ballet
class can I borrow your bike and she
took off on the bike but then and that
was the last time
so uh so yeah
so the parole officer uh recognized him
from the sketch and so uh called the
cops and said hey I know that
[__] so then they went to
running I'll call his mom's house his
mom lived in Monterey Park
and uh in the house they actually found
a Rental receipt for a Seattle storage
locker now in this Locker they found
earrings belonging to Robin samso the
victim uh actually the I think the
earrings were her mom's but she had been
wearing them that day they were like
little gold like ball earrings
so Rodney lacala gets arrested in July
of 1979 and um you know held without
bail in 1980
he was put on trial and he got convicted
of this one murder and he was sentenced
to death
but
the California Supreme Court
overturned it the death sentence because
I guess like the the jurors they had
told the jurors about his prior sex
crimes like the rape and stuff that he
had done like on uh Tali Shapiro and all
that other kind of stuff and I guess
that was like supposed to be
inadmissible because that's kind of how
they do well in some of the cases is
they're not supposed to because it
prejudices the jury out of blood you had
to block so I guess the jury had been
informed about those and so they said
well he didn't really get a fair trial
so they overturned the death sentence
now it so happened that in 1986 they put
him on trial again for the same crime
and it went pretty much the same way
except they didn't tell the jury about
the prior sex crimes but he got
convicted and sentenced to death again
that's the second time but then in 2001
the ninth Circuit Court of Appeals they
overturned the second conviction because
of some weird [__] technicality
um the technicality had something I'm
not real clear on why this was but
apparently there was
[Music]
um
Rodney Alcala argued that the park
ranger who had found Robin samso's body
like in the Foothills had been
hypnotized by the police
and the fact that he supposedly had a
witness that was willing to argue that
wasn't allowed to I don't know like
wasn't allowed to like speak at the
trial was like enough to I don't know if
that was the only thing but there was
some kind of like technicality where
they the appeals court like overturned
the second
death sentence the second conviction
so at this point it's [__] up well at
this point okay so in 2003 like uh
Orange County and they're like we are
gonna get this [__] God damn it
it's like so they are like we're going
after him again same thing like so it's
the third third prosecution this was in
2003.
and then they found out that um Rodney
alcala's DNA had been sampled under that
state law where if you get arrested for
because I think Most states have this
now or if you get arrested for a sex
crime they automatically take your DNA
so they can check you against like other
sex crimes because you know usually it's
not just one they've usually done a
bunch of them
so um and apparently Rodney Alcala for
obvious reasons uh was not a big fan of
this taking your DNA when you get
arrested for a sex crime but [__] him
because that's how they knew that he did
like some of these other ones
so they so they found out that they had
collected his um his DNA so they said
well we're going to go through like all
these cold cases we're gonna like put
some more [__] on here and make sure
that he gets convicted this time and it
sticks you know what I'm saying because
it's like the third time
so they actually found out that um
they had a cold case DNA match in uh
2004 so they matched him to like a bunch
of other cases so what they did was they
were gonna um try him for the robin
samso murder again like the 12 year old
and then
um through the DNA they actually piled
on like four more cases that they had
matched his DNA to and these were an 18
year old woman named Jill barcone she
was um originally from New York she was
a runaway but she was actually killed in
Los Angeles in 1977.
um she was the one that they originally
thought the Hillside Strangler had
killed her but no it was Rodney Alcala
they matched his DNA to it
um also a 27 year old woman named
Georgia wickstead she was actually
killed in her uh apartment in Malibu
also in 1977.
um a 31 year old named Charlotte lamb
she'd been raped and strangled and she
was actually left dead in the laundry
room of her apartment complex in El
Segundo that was 1978. and uh Jill
parento that was uh she was 21 and she
was killed in her apartment in Burbank
in 1979. so those were four more that
they know that he did because they were
DNA match so they said well we're going
to add those four on so we're gonna do
five like all how he got into people's
apartments and in the people's
laundromats he just walked around and I
guess walked into people's apartments or
or did he was he using his [__]
photography gigs to get in there
yeah it might have been and I mean from
he must have been at least superficially
like I said much like Ted Bundy I guess
confident Charming yada yada because
most people and it's interesting because
I was watching they were actually
talking about his Dating Game appearance
but they said
um it was interesting that you know when
he was just trying out for the show when
he was on the show like on camera like
he seemed pretty normal like he seems
creepy to us now because we know who he
is and like we know what he did but I
think if you were just like watching it
I don't think you would have noticed
anything different but they said
interestingly when people started
interacting with him one-on-one like
behind the scenes in the green room or
whatever then they started to notice
that he was creepy but he was able to
put up a facade
of being normal for at least a short
time you know yeah so
um so I kind of feel like it was maybe
that kind of situation where he was like
a photographer and he didn't seem creepy
at first and he's just like maybe he
seemed really professional but then by
the time you know 5 10 15 minutes had
gone by and you'd interacted with him
and you're like oh my God I think
there's something wrong with this dude
then it might be like too [__] late
you know what I'm saying so he was able
to like act normal for long enough to
like get people into his clutches you
know yeah so I kind of feel like maybe
that was the situation
the [__] up thing about these four
women that he killed
um he was one of those [__]
where he would because like I said he'd
usually strangle them and he'd like kind
of [__] around with him where they'd
kind of strangle him with his hands and
then like he just let him go unconscious
and let him wake up and then he'd like
do their nylons and [__] like that
um he would also after he killed them he
also like posed them he was one of those
[__]
um the lewd poses and everything yeah
like that kind of [__] yeah that kind of
[__]
so yeah
uh so interestingly while he was in jail
like while they were preparing because
like I said the third conviction they
really wanted it to stick so they said
well you know he's been it's been
overturned two times just for that one
poor little 12 year old girl so that's
why they were trying to find more crimes
that he had done so they could like
stack him up you know what I mean so he
wouldn't like get away
so while he was in jail while they were
preparing the third trial
uh Rodney Alcala wrote and published a
book because of course he did uh called
you the jury
and uh he said that he had not killed
Robin samso
um and said somebody else did it I don't
know who he said to it because I'm not
going to read the [__]
um also this is special he also
um filed some lawsuits against the
California penal system
uh one lawsuit was because they wouldn't
give him a low-fat diet
and one lawsuit was because he said that
he slipped and fell like in the prison
so absolutely failure [__] yeah I
think both of them were I'm not getting
my little fat diet you're trying to kill
me from cholesterol that's yeah that's
essentially what he was arguing yeah see
and that's another thing that these
[__] always do like the second
they get caught then they just start
crying yeah you know what I mean they
just start whining about this and the
other thing holy crap
so yeah so in 2003 the prosecutors were
finally like okay we're gonna do
five victims now what they're now Alcala
and his attorneys did not want that to
happen obviously because they're like
okay well it's gonna be a lot harder to
get him
off on these charges if there's five of
them and four of them have actual DNA
evidence I'm like well yeah that's
that's the deal you know what I mean
that's that's what they're trying to do
but they you know they were mad but
anyway they let it go on they're like
yeah you can do all five
so um because they took it all the way
to the Supreme Court but the Supreme
Court said no you can you can stack them
all together so they um so 2006 uh they
the Supreme Court said okay you can go
ahead with it but then it was another
several few like another several years
so it wasn't actually until 2010 uh that
Rodney Alcala stood trial for those five
murders
now as I mentioned I don't think he did
this at the first two trials which maybe
you know I'm not really sure why he
didn't but for the third trial the big
one
he uh decided he was gonna act uh as his
own attorney like you know much like Ted
Bundy did
so he gets up there this is [__]
crazy
so he gets up there
and he
actually like cross-examined himself in
two different voices
hmm you know what I mean like he'd go
and he'd like as he'd make his voice
deeper and like Mr Alcala did you blah
blah and then he'd be like oh well I did
this thing and you know what I mean like
he did that kind of [__] and I'm like
okay that's way to make yourself seem
like a normal person to the jury I'm
like everyone's like oh my God this
motherfucker's [__] crazy if I saw
somebody doing that in the [__]
courtroom like okay guilty guilty please
put them away Jesus Christ so yeah so he
did that
um and then also the only excuse that he
could come up with
for he's like oh well he didn't kill
uh the little girl Robin samso because
oh I was at Knott's Berry Farm I was
applying for a job as a photographer
there so it couldn't have been me and so
then they were like well yeah but what
about the other four that we have your
DNA from yeah
um and he's just like um I don't
remember that was basically his defense
I don't remember killing them yeah so I
so I couldn't have I'm like
made up
yeah
it's just the way people made that up I
guess no no DNA yeah he didn't uh
yeah
that was all he came up with that was
all he came up with he was either at
Knott's Berry Farm and I didn't kidnap
the little girl and then the other one's
just like I don't remember doing that
white people make it up DNA why people
make it up outer space satellites making
that all up yeah we made it all up made
it all up
Earth's flat
satellites up there just
balloons man they're just using it with
balloons they're shooting the balloons
down all time now
no orbit
okay
no I just like the I like the uh
Luddite
yeah non-technology [__]
I've run into people that don't believe
into DNA
yeah I don't really believe DNA you
don't even really believe in DNA guess
what it doesn't give it doesn't matter
if you believe it or yeah DNA believes
in you yeah okay no one gives a [__] if
you believe it or not it's still there
sorry
well that's the thing I don't I don't
really know well it's just kind of like
all those people that like didn't
believe in evolution I said I don't give
a [__] if you don't believe in it it
happened yeah you know it's and you're
just wrong you can believe whatever you
want but you know it's okay
like I said whether you believe it or
not is completely immaterial because
you're [__] nobody so
you know what I'm saying uh so yeah
also this was this is fun he also in the
closing arguments uh he didn't really
have a closing argument as such however
he did play uh the song Alice's
Restaurant by Arlo Guthrie and uh
specifically pointed out some of the
details it's like an anti-vietnam song
in case you haven't heard it it's very
famous the song is
um and basically there's a part in the
song where there's like lyrics about
wanting to kill and stuff like that and
he just like played that and was just
kind of like huh huh yeah and
everybody's like okay yeah so there was
that
um so yeah the jury
wisely deliberated for less than two
days and then they're like yeah guilty
all five counts Jesus Christ uh and as I
said at this particular trial they also
got um his original victim the
eight-year-old girl that lived
um Tali Shapiro she actually came and
testified at this trial too like she's a
grown-up now obviously but um yeah so
she came and uh did that and they hadn't
told those she was like a surprise
witness so that might have you know it
probably didn't help like I said that he
was like trying to
advocate for himself because he clearly
came across like a [__] nutcase
actually when he got older like he just
let his hair grow out and then it went
totally white and he looked kind of like
a [__] up weird serial killer Howard
Stern a little bit yeah yeah I was
thinking that
[__] Howard Stern
before Stern turned into a pelican
because he looks like a pelican now
I haven't seen him in a long time but
it's just like it was mostly just the
hair that was reminding me like the hair
and kind of like the thin face yeah like
kind of reminded me of Howard Stern
because he had like that long like curly
hair like that yeah poor old house
he used to [__] make fun of this old
dude named Don Imus for being an old
stick in the mud [__] retro DJ and
he'd be [__] with Don Imus 24 7 and
that's exactly who Howard Stern has
turned into he's turned into Don Imus
for you go Stern fans you know exactly
what I'm talking about
[__] Stern
poor guy irrelevant okay
well everybody gets irrelevance yeah
everybody becomes relevant pretty much
that's just the way it's hard to stay
relevant when you get old yeah it's
that's just the way it is yeah I hate to
tell you uh but yeah so uh so yeah so he
got convicted technically and got
sentenced to death
for the third time yeah so and they and
it actually stuck that time so they
actually like threw him on death row
now as I mentioned
in uh like earlier on in March of 2010
um the New York City Police Department
and the Huntington Beach California
police department they released 120 of
um Rodney alcala's photographs that
they'd found in one of his uh in his
storage locker or his storage um unit
that they found
and they uh were looking for you know
they wanted people to help them like
identify us because they didn't know who
any of these people were it's like some
of these people might be dead it's like
might be other victims it may be you
know uh maybe they're buried somewhere
and missing we don't know it might be
cold cases so they were trying to like
get everybody to like help them out
um there were 900 photos that as I
mentioned earlier could not be shown
because they were uh sexually explicit
now uh after they first made the photos
public uh 21 women came forward and
identified themselves uh so they were
still alive obviously
um because that would be weird if they
were dead and they identified themselves
but um they also had six families come
forward
um and say that they recognized uh the
women in the photos but that the women
were missing like that they disappeared
so they so they don't know like I said
exactly how many people Rodney Alcala
killed because there are a lot of
photographs and they don't know who all
of those people are
now none of the people in the photos
were connected definitively to any
missing person or unsolved murder case
until 2013.
a family member recognized one of the
photos as a woman named Christine
Thornton who was 28. they actually found
her body in Wyoming in 1982 uh and so
that was that was the only one so far
that they've uh matched up
so as of I think there's still 110 of
the photos up like online now I think
it's on the FBI website and maybe on the
um New York City Police Department and
stuff so you can go there and look and
see if you recognize anybody because
they're still looking for
um you know because there's still a lot
of these people that are not identified
and they don't know if those people are
murder victims or what
now so what ended up happening after he
got um sentenced to death in 2010
um the New York authorities were like
well you know he killed people there too
obviously but they're like well he's
already
in prison so it's like there's not
really any point in pursuing him for the
murderers here because he's already on
death row there
um but they did actually a grand jury
did indict him like in absentia
for um murdering Cornelia Crilley and
Ellen hover in 1971 was the first one in
the 1977 and then he actually did get
extradited to New York
um for that but they he entered a plea
of not guilty but they you know he was
guilty anyway
um so uh so yeah so I think he like
changed his plea to guilty like later on
and then he got another 25 years like on
top of that but like I said he's you
know he was on death row
uh there were also they think that he
might have
killed
um because they have a few other cases
that they think that he might have been
responsible for uh there was a 13 year
old girl named Antoinette Whittaker who
was killed in July of 1977 that and they
think that he might have done that and a
17 year old girl named Joyce gauntz that
was February 1978 uh so they think he
might have been involved in that as well
there was also a disappearance I don't
believe they found her body but it was a
20 year old woman named Sherry Ann
Greenman that was in 1976 in September
um and they uh they think that he was
probably involved in uh those and they
found like I said in his storage locker
they not only found like all his photos
but they also found jewelry like
belonging to some of the victims as well
and some of the jewelry like earrings
and stuff had DNA on it which is how
they were able to like match them
so basically uh there was also another
murder that happened in 1977 a 19 year
old girl named Pamela Jean Lampson and
she actually went to Fisherman's Wharf
and then disappeared they think that um
you know and she was going there like to
model for somebody so they think
probably
um that he killed her as well yeah
because they actually did find her like
all beat up and raped like later on like
near a hiking trail
um they didn't find any DNA on or
anything like that but yeah that did
sound like his Mo so he also got in
September of 2016 they're just like
adding the [__] charges on he got
charged with another murder uh 28 year
old Christine Thornton who I think I
mentioned earlier she disappeared in
1977 uh and they recognized her as like
in what a relative recognized her in one
of the uh photos that they had made um
public now her body was actually found
in 82 like I said but she wasn't
identified until 2015.
now Rodney Alcala when they asked him
about it he said oh yeah I took that
picture but he wouldn't admit to like
killing her uh she was actually six
months pregnant when she was murdered uh
so yeah now they were going to extradite
him to Wyoming to um stand trial for
that particular murder but at that point
he was 73 and he was in very ill health
and so he didn't make the journey
so it happened that in July of 2021 this
[__] finally dropped dead at the
age of 77 unspecified natural causes so
even though he was on death row he never
did get executed he just [__] died
and um
you know I was I was watching this
documentary like I said from 2017 so
Rodney Alcala was still alive then and
one of the investigators that worked on
the case was like very he was
unequivocal about he's like man I hope
he's suffering it's like I heard he was
in ill health I hope he's suffering it's
like I hope one day I could assume that
I could just wake up and like he'll be
[__] gone and I don't have to hear
about him anymore when nobody has to
like you know what I mean because he had
been the one that had been like dealing
with the families of like the kids that
he killed and [__] like that and he's
just like not having it so
yeah so everybody was like pretty I'm
sure everybody was like pretty [__]
happy when that [__] died but
yeah he died in 2021
so kind of like a Bundy type yeah it's
funny how he's not as famous as Bundy I
guess uh there wasn't as much of him you
know recorded in the newsrooms you know
what I mean
uh he Bundy kind of did some exciting
[__] where he's jumping out the back the
windows of [__] courthouses and going
on the run for a while
but he was a little bit more of an
exciting story
also his murders were more
uh lurid
so maybe that's why this guy really
doesn't get the notoriety and we don't
they don't know how many of me killed
Bundy killed a lot more or they know
that Bundy killed a lot more than this
yeah this guy I mean this guy could have
killed a lot more but they're not really
sure because it's like even up until the
time he died they kept like finding more
ones and being like yeah this was
probably him too kind of um it's kind of
unusual for serial killer not to uh get
caught and then want to take claim all
claim all the credit for all the ones
that he killed they usually like to get
all the credit
but this dude here he's probably
a control type freak his only means his
only means of a control over the
authorities at this point is to withhold
information so he's one of those yeah a
lot of [__] was like I ain't
telling you nothing you know I mean and
that was his power he was locked up but
he wasn't using it to barter to
negotiate so it was something
pathological more than practical because
you should have known that he wasn't
gonna walk
he had gotten rewards if he was in
prison had he become a confession
machine he says I'll tell you what
there's another murder I did I'll tell
you about it but I want out here I want
McDonald's
you know I mean [__] like that worked
for Henry Lee Lucas yeah over and over
and over again yeah I guess if he if
he's actually delivering and given given
names and pointing them out in the
pictures and he's going this one right
here I left her body over here you know
and then then they that would actually
give him incentive
to later on where he could do it again
because I think I'm ready to tell you
about another one you know that's he
could have played that game for his
final years yeah and got no gotten out
going on little trips and [__] outside
the prison
but this guy really doesn't
strike me as like uh real brilliant
he kind of strikes me as being dumb
yeah some of some of the [__] that he
did
like moving around but then using his
real name after he's committed crimes
and wanted under that name that's and
then going on game shows
that's not being bold that's being dumb
yeah
so
he didn't know how to use what he had
once he got caught
like you know
BTK
he's caught if he was able to hold if he
if he'd had other murders that you know
if he was holding those underneath here
so I can close to his chest he could
come out every now and then goes oh by
the way there's one of them you don't
know about you know and then he'd be
able to go on tour yeah because I feel
like a lot of them do that right because
like you said it's it's an ultimate
power play right yeah and I think you
know uh investigators know that but
they're like look we just want the
bodies found you know what I mean we
just want more [__] to pin on you yeah
so it's like you can play these little
power games all you want yeah well they
want to get out of the prison they want
to go see outside they want to go to
McDonald's They want to get attention
you know they want people to [__]
talk to them so and and then they're
gonna give that they're going to give
them a case in exchange and then you
know they can [__] play it against
the cops you're like don't you want this
family to have peace to finally know
what happened you know what I mean
they're gonna go yeah yeah so they're
gonna do what he says yeah especially if
he delivers if he delivers on one then
he can do it over and over and over
again and this dude probably had a whole
bunch of murders he probably could have
done that with at least five
and you can milk five over over a decade
over a period of a decade easily yeah
two one case every two years yeah
so and I have a feeling he did
substantly a lot more than that there's
probably a lot more I mean they know for
sure that it was eight but it's like
there was a lot more that they suspect
him of well just that one you told me
the girl disappeared one for a photo
shoot and then found on that footpath he
did that I'm pretty sure he probably the
dates the location the mo that was his
and there's going to be a bunch more
yeah I I suspect that they're if he was
killing women in laundry rooms in the
apartment complexes and up in their
apartments that means he was doing Peep
and Tom [__] going into their houses or
talking his way into people's houses too
so they weren't all that Mo that was
only part of his day yeah he had more
than one probably
and they they only cracked the
photography ammo
because that was you know it was easy
one to get him on yeah but he may have
had another one you know looking for my
lost dog or I'm looking for my wife that
type of [__] you know
why are you in my apartment this isn't
this isn't your apartment you know that
kind of [__]
yeah because I'm sure they have like a
whole little bag of tricks yeah that
they use what do you mean this is your
apartment oh they changed the numbers or
something you know the the serial killer
come up with anything just to throw
somebody off balance for a few seconds
to get an advantage somebody opened the
door and then boom then they [__] get
in there some of them dress up as like
uh maintenance workers and [__] too the
cable man dressed up as the cable man or
like you know oh I came over to like
figure landlord came over and like said
to come over and fix your plumbing or
something yeah I got there yeah I got it
I've heard of a couple of them doing
that guy yeah gotta get in there
something wrong with your [__] um
uh
what do you call it a circuit breaker
your circuit breakers are something
wrong with them I got to come in and
check there you go yeah
I feel like that's probably I mean I'm
not giving anybody any ideas but I'm
just saying I feel like that's any of
those dudes that do that [__] have
[__] researched all the other ones
yeah
I mean I feel like that's the one that's
most likely to work yeah I mean it was
just like some random ass [__]
showed up at your door but he's like no
you're not coming in but if you have
like a uniform and a clipboard and yeah
like look like you're if you look like
you have a job like yeah then it's more
likely I think nowadays probably most
people would be like yeah no I'm still
not letting you in but like I think back
in the 70s probably they would have I'm
sure it would happen today if a dude
showed up with a clipboard and a hard
hat and came up and says oh by the way
[__] Nate told me how to come in here
there's a gas leak in the neighborhood
yeah yeah why come on you know I'd bring
I'd let him in
the thing is I'd probably whip his ass
too
okay big difference
I'm not 100 pound female that's what I
mean 100 pound male yeah I feel well
yeah so it's not as you know
it doesn't behoove you the risk isn't
there for you right no the only big
dudes there ever been after me want me
to go on their only fans with them
hey man want to make gate forward
and make all kinds of money
oh come on we don't have to kiss or
anything
my girlfriend film it all
Zach says uh one can certainly at least
admire the Olympic pool size balls this
[__] had yeah yeah I guess so
I don't know I don't really buy or
anything about these but
I
like you said it almost seemed like
he didn't he doesn't seem real
um
charismatic I guess that's kind of why a
lot of people are fascinated by Ted
Bundy even though I never found Ted
Bundy particularly charismatic but um a
lot of it a lot of people did they're
graded on a curve four serial killers
Ted Bundy was
didn't get much better than that
you know what I mean that's yeah he's
about the normal like he kind of had a
job like he looked like he had his
pretty intelligent he could he could do
stuff but he didn't have discipline to
follow through he wasn't the kind of guy
that could actually hold down a career
he tried yeah he wasn't even a very good
student he couldn't stay focused on that
stuff kind of scatterbrained I think
yeah
but I mean when you think about it
because I think
when people think about serial killers
they think of people like Ted Bundy or
something like that but I kind of feel
like a lot of serial killers just look
like scumbags Kinda Yeah
like some of them have jobs and stuff
but
well they had that one guy who was
recent who kept that woman in that
storage shed
remember he shot her husband and he had
her chained up in there and I think they
actually saved that one but he had
killed three or four more yeah and he
was actually buying shovels and then off
of Amazon
and then right in the Shelf says this is
good if you ever need to bury some body
oh that's right yeah we need to do him
and he was that [__] it was
pretty recent yeah
and uh if you were to look at him he
just looked like a average [__] Farm
redneck type guy
you know I wouldn't say redneck just
country kind of I don't know but he
looked he didn't really stand up he was
a wacko though
um see you never can tell yeah and he
would
pull a gun on a couple and kill the
husband and then abduct the wife put her
in a damn storage shed chain her up in
there
and go in there and feed her and visit
her and
have sex with her until he was sick over
any killer barrier right right in there
in that area
they ever found other ones buried up
there I think he's still alive I don't I
think he surrendered or did they kill
him I don't remember I'd have to like
look it up again but I did remember like
I I remembered when you said about how
you you rated stuff on Amazon yeah he
was buying stuff he was writing reviews
he was buying stuff off Amazon to
dispose of bodies and to do things and
and actually write in the reviews and
saying oh yeah this is good if you need
any bodies to bury this is the one and
then you know just [__] like oh yeah
this chain will hold a woman down all
night long that kind of just [__] like
that
which then like I said nobody would
think because people write a joke yeah
because people write joke reviews on
Amazon all the time so so yeah so but he
probably knew it's like oh nobody
everybody will just say another thing
seriously yeah because everybody writes
funny shows all the time
okay all right so um are we are are we
done yeah do we have anything else you
like because I know you're not really
feeling all that one yeah yeah I need to
get some sleep yeah I do as well because
I gotta get up early in the morning like
always yeah and I also got up very early
this morning I still I'm not super super
tired for a change but I would like to
kind of relax for an hour or two before
I go to sleep uh but yeah so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this show uh like I
said I've been wanting to do this topic
for a while so I'm glad we finally got
around to it
so uh so yeah so thank you everybody for
dropping by and hanging out with us this
evening thank you for super chats we
will be back again on Friday night at 7
30 p.m Eastern Standard time for our
Sidetrack show please remember to hit
that like button and uh comment do all
that other kind of stuff you know push
it up in the algorithms you guys know
how YouTube works so we would appreciate
you guys doing that and I guess we will
see you guys again on Friday night good
night